Speaker 1: Why don't we go next to
Nico from New Hampshire? Nico, welcome.
Speaker 3: David, how are you? I'm doing well. So
I'm a student in clinical psychology. Actually, I
care a great deal about empathy. With the midterm
elections in the rise and my question for you is
why do you think modern politicians
refuse to empathize with each other?
Speaker 1: Why do they refuse to empathize? You
know, I don't know if refuse is necessarily the
right word. I mean, I think they don't empathize
with each other. But for some of these people,
they seem unable to imagine what it would be
like to be in the position of someone else.
It seems like they're just unable to do it.
So I don't know if refuse is the right word.
Speaker 3: E And perhaps in the public setting
in the public eye as opposed to outside?
Speaker 1: Well, I do think that in that
sense, there's probably some belief,
maybe it's it's accurate, even that
if you empathize with the other side,
that you're ceding ground to them rhetorically so
that then all of a sudden you end up backed into
a corner. I don't know. I mean, I'm thinking out
loud I can understand how they might think that.
Speaker 3: Yeah, I was kind of having a similar
mindset and a kind of a fear of looking weak or
conceding. So I agree with that. Another question
is why do you think seemingly basic amounts of
empathy that you'd think would be weak in
all people, which I like to think is common
and they're not reflected in our lives?
Speaker 1: Can you give me an example of that?
Speaker 3: Well, we can look at the abortion
laws at this moment, and now we'll go on to the
context of, you know, morality. And that's a whole
other discussion. But the reality of wanting to
help others, seeing that people are struggling
in certain areas, that's not prioritizing.
Speaker 1: Yeah, I mean, I think that's the
case in some of these anti-abortion states. But
but that. So you're saying there are state level
abortion laws that show no empathy, right? Yeah,
I agree with that. I agree with that. I mean, I
think that's the way that they're designed. You've
got people writing these laws who sometimes who
have a very black, white or sometimes religiously
oriented oriented view about abortion. And they
what you and I would call empathy, they would call
they would they might call sin or immorality. And
so if that you're not going to be you're not going
to willingly put that stuff into a law.
Speaker 3: Okay. Well, thanks for asking
those questions. Have a good rest of your day.
Speaker 1: All right. And that was Nico from New
Haven. I incorrectly said New Hampshire, but that
was Nico from New Haven. Let's take a very quick
break. If you're holding, don't hang up because
we're going right back to the phones in a moment.